welcome everyone this is part five in
our series on analysis methods in nlp
we're going to be talking about feature
attribution methods this is
fundamentally a powerful toolkit for
helping you understand how the features
in your model contribute to its output
predictions
our fundamental question here is kind of
why does your model make the predictions
that it makes there are many motivations
for asking this question here just a few
to start you might just want to
understand whether your model is
systematic with regard to some specific
linguistic phenomenon has it actually
captured that phenomenon
you might also want to know whether it's
robust to minor perturbations in its
input
you might use these techniques to
diagnose unwanted biases in your model
and relatedly you might use them to find
weaknesses in your model that an
adversary could exploit to lead your
model to do really problematic things
fundamentally i think that this is a
tool kit that will help you write really
excellent analysis sections for your
paper to that end i'm going to try to
show you a bunch of code that will help
you get hands-on with these techniques
i'll do it at a kind of high level in
the screencast and i've just contributed
this new notebook feature attribution to
the course code repository and that
should be flexible and adaptable and
help you take these techniques and apply
them to whatever models and ideas you're
exploring for your projects
the star of our show really the only
reason that i can do this is this
amazing captain.ai library it implements
a wide range of feature attribution
techniques we're going to talk
extensively about the integrated
gradients method and use the gradient
based method as a kind of simple
baseline for that method but as you can
see here captive implements a wide range
of different algorithms some very
particular to specific model designs and
others completely agnostic about what
kind of model you're exploring so it's a
very exciting toolkit
the sundar rajan at all 2017 paper
introduced the integrated gradients
method it's also a lovely contribution
because it gives us a kind of
framework for thinking about feature
attribution methods in general and as
part of that they offer two axioms that
i'm going to use to guide this
discussion the first and the more
important one is sensitivity
if two inputs x and x prime differ only
at dimension i and lead to different
predictions then the feature associated
with that dimension must have non-zero
attribution
and with my simple example here you can
get a sense for why sensitivity is such
a fundamental axiom if for some model m
and three dimensional input one zero one
we get a prediction of positive and if
for that same model the input one one
one leads to the prediction negative
then we really ought to expect that the
feature associated with the second
position must have non-zero attribution
because it must be decisive in leading
the model to make these two different
predictions
the second axiom is going to be less
important to our discussion but it's
nonetheless worth having in mind it is
implementation and variance if two
models m and m prime have identical
input output behavior then the
attributions for m and m prime are
identical this is really just saying
that the attributions we give should be
separate from any incidental differences
in model implementation that don't
affect the input output behavior of that
model
to start our discussion let's begin with
this simple baseline which is simply
multiplying the gradients by the inputs
this is implemented and kept them as
input by gradient now i'm showing with
respect to some particular feature i
given model m and input x then we simply
get the gradients for that feature
and then multiply it by the actual value
of that feature it's as simple as that
here are two implementations the first
one in cell 2 does this for kind of
using raw pi torch just to show you how
we can use pi torch's auto grad
functionality to implement this method
and the second implementation is from
captum and it's probably more flexible
and it uses this input by gradient class
to give you a full illustration here
i've just set up a simple synthetic
classification problem using scikit
tools
my model will be a torch shallow neural
classifier which i fit on that data
and then in cells 9 and 10 i use those
two implementations of this method and
you can see in 11 and 12 that they give
identical outputs
another thing worth noting here is that
i have used the method by taking
gradients with respect to the actual
labels in our data set
you can often get a different picture if
you take gradients with respect to the
predictions of that model and that might
give you a better sense for why the
model is making the predictions that it
makes
in this case since the model is very
good the attributions are only slightly
different
that's our kind of baseline i want to
show you now that the input by gradients
method fails the sensitivity test and
this is an example from the cinderella
at all paper if they give this simple
model m here which is effectively just
rel u applied to one minus the input and
then you take one minus that rel
calculation there that's the model it's
got one dimensional inputs and outputs
if you calculate for input zero you get
an outcome of zero
and if you give the model input 2 you
get an output of 1.
since we have differing output
predictions sensitivity tells us that we
have to have differing attributions
for these two cases here these two
one-dimensional inputs but unfortunately
when you calculate through with this
method you get zero attribution in both
cases
that's a failure of sensitivity and
points to a weakness of this method
let's move now to integrated gradients
and let me start by giving you the
intuition for how this method is going
to work imagine we have a simple
two-dimensional feature space feature x1
and x2 so here's the actual
point represented here
the idea behind integrated gradients is
that we're going to compare that with
respect to some baseline the typical
baseline for us will be the all zeros
vector
and then to do the comparison what we'll
actually do is interpolate a bunch of
points between that baseline and our
actual input
take gradients with respect to each one
of them and average all of those
gradient results and that will give us a
measure of feature importance
here's the calculation of the method in
full detail i've taken this presentation
from this really excellent tutorial from
tensorflow integrated gradients
and it does all these annotations that i
find quite helpful here's fundamentally
how this works the core thing is in
purple we're going to interpolate a
bunch of different inputs between that
baseline of all zeros and our actual
input that's what's happening here and
we'll take the gradients with respect to
each one of those with respect to each
one of the features
and we're going to sum those up and
average them and that gives us the core
calculation here
and then in five we just kind of scale
that resulting average with respect to
the original input to put it back on the
same scale and as i show here integrated
gradients obeys the sensitivity axiom
let's go back to that original example
of a simple value based model
presented here i showed you that the
input by gradients method failed
sensitivity for this model
integrated gradients of course is
sensitive in the relevant sense and you
can kind of see why that's happening
because our core calculation now is not
with respect to a single input in the
case of the input 2 but rather with
respect to all of those interpolated
feature representations although some of
those interpolated feature
representations give a gradient of zero
not all of them do and the result in
effect is that you'll get a feature
attribution of approximately one for
this case of an input two
the desired result showing sensitivity
because of course the input of zero in
this case will give an attribution of
zero
now let me walk you through a few
examples that show you how you can use
captum to get hands-on with the
integrated gradients method i'm going to
do that for two classes of model the
first one is just a simple feed forward
network and what i'm doing is
reconnecting with the stanford sentiment
tree bank that we use during our
sentiment unit so on this slide i've
just set up an ssd experiment using
sst.experiment
from that sst module
my feature representations are going to
be essentially a bag of words and i've
filtered off stock words to make this a
little more interpretable
and our classifier is a torch shallow
neural classifier
i run the experiment and a lot of
information about that experiment you'll
recall is stored in this variable
experiment
here i extract the model from that that
experiment report
and here we get a bunch of other
metadata that we're going to use to run
the integrated gradients method the
feature representations of our test
examples the actual labels
and the predicted labels along with the
feature names and the one thing to note
here is that for the sake of captain we
need to turn the string class names into
their corresponding indices and that's
what's happening in cell line here
then we set up the integrated gradients
using the forward method for our model
and we set up the baseline which is that
all zeros vector and then finally use
the attribute method and here i'm taking
attributions with respect to the
predictions of the model
i think this can be a powerful device
for doing some simple error analysis and
that's what i've set up on the slide
here i've offered two functions error
analysis and create attribution lookup
that will help you understand how
features in this model are relating to
its output predictions you can see in
cell 14 here i'm looking for cases where
the actual label is neutral and the
model predicted positive we can find
those attributions and this is actually
an informative picture here it looks
like the model has overfit features like
the period and the comma those ought to
be indicative of the neutral category
but here it's using them in ways that
lead to a positive prediction so that's
something that we might want to address
and we can go one level further if we
choose and look at individual examples
so here i've pulled out an individual
example no one goes unindicted here
which is probably for the best this is a
case where the correct label is neutral
and our model predicted positive and i
think the attributions again help us
understand why because by far the
feature with the highest attribution is
this best one
and this is revealing that the model
just does not understand the context in
which the word best is used in this
example that might point to a
fundamental weakness of the bag of words
approach
for my second example let's connect with
transformer models since i assume that a
lot of you will be working with these
models and these present exciting new
opportunities for feature attribution
because in these models we have so many
representations that we could think
about doing attributions for here's a
kind of general picture of a vert-like
model where i have the outputs up here
you have many layers of transformer
block outputs those are given in purple
then probably an embedding layer in
green and that embedding layer might be
itself composed of like a word embedding
layer and a positional embedding layer
and maybe others
all of these layers are potential
targets for integrated gradients and cap
them again makes that relatively easy
so to start this off i just downloaded
from hugging face a
roberta based twitter sentiment model
that seemed really interesting and i
wrote a predict one prabha method that
will help us with the error analysis
that we want to do
this next step here does the encodings
of both the actual example using the
models tokenizer as well as the baseline
of all zeros that we'll use for
comparisons
in cell seven i've just designed a small
custom forward method to help captain
out because this model has slightly
different output structure than is
expected
here in cell 8 we set up the layer that
we want to target as you can see i'm
targeting the embedding layer but many
other layers could be targeted captain
makes that easy
for our example we use this is
illuminating which i'll take to have
true class positive
we do our encodings in cell 11 of both
the actual example and the baseline and
then that's the basis for our
attribution of this single example
now for burnt because we have high
dimensional representations for each one
of the tokens that we're looking at we
need to perform another layer of
compression that we didn't have to for
the feed forward example as you can see
here the attributions have for one
example
dimensionality 6 by 768 this is one
vector per word token
to summarize those at the level of
individual word tokens we'll just sum
them up and then z-score normalize them
to kind of put them on a consistent
scale so that will reduce the
attributions down to one per subword
token
and that feeds into our final kind of
cumulative analysis so we'll do the
probabilistic predictions
we'll get the actual class
convert the input to something that
captain can digest and then use this
visualization data record method to
bring this all together into a nice
tabular visualization and that's what's
happening here you can see for our
example we have the true label the
predicted label with the associated
probability
and then the really interesting part
per word token we have a summary of its
attributions and you can see that green
is associated with positive white with
neutral and red with negative and this
is giving us a reassuring picture about
the systematicity of these predictions
it's a positive prediction and most of
that is the result of the word
illuminating and the exclamation mark
and that kind of feeds into a nice kind
of error analysis slash challenge
analysis that you can do of models like
this using captum for this slide here
i've posed a little challenge or
adversarial test to see how deeply my
model understands sentences like they
said it would be great and they were
right
you can see it makes the correct
prediction in that case and when i
change it to they said it would be great
and they were wrong it predicts negative
that's reassuring and so are the feature
attributions it seems to be keying into
exactly the pieces of information that i
would hope and even doing it in a
context-sensitive way
for the next two examples i just change
up the syntax to see whether it's kind
of over fit to the position of these
words in the string and it again looks
robust they were right to say that it
would be great
prediction of positive they were wrong
to say that it would be great prediction
of negative very reassuring as is the
second to last example they said it
would be stellar and they were correct
the only disappointing thing in this
challenge problem is for this final
example it predicts neutral for they
said it would be stellar and they were
incorrect and the attributions are also
a little bit worrisome about the extent
to which the model has truly understood
this example
uh maybe we can think about how to
address that problem but the fundamental
takeaway for now is simply that you can
see how you can use feature attribution
together with challenge examples to kind
of hone in on exactly how systematic a
model model's predictions are for an
interesting class of cases